le conseil d'état en 1905 dans un
village du sud de la france un taureau
fou s'échappe du marché aux bestiaux
il sème la panique dans les rues du
village la police se met à poursuivre le
taureau mais l'animal est insaisissable
il faut le tuer avant qu'il n'en corps
d'un habitant
les policiers tirent sur la pauvre bête
qui finit par succomber dans la
fusillade
une balle perdue transperce la fenêtre
d'un riverain du nom de tomaso gréco
celui ci est blessé
il porte plainte contre l'état le
conseil d'état rend un arrêt qui
disculpent la police parce que celle ci
était en opération mais pour la première
fois le principe d'une mise en cause de
l'état est posée c'est avec des affaires
comme celle là et au fil des arrêts
rendus par le conseil d'état que se sont
constitués les règles qui précise la
responsabilité de l'état et les limites
de son action
un particulier peut très bien contester
une décision de l'état
il le fera devant le tribunal fait pour
ça le tribunal administratif s'il n'est
pas satisfait de la décision du tribunal
administratif
il fera appel devant le conseil d'état
qui aura le dernier mot
mais le conseil d'état n'est pas qu'une
institution chargée de rendre la justice
les conseillers d'état sont comme leurs
noms l'indiquent des conseillers de
l'état le conseil d'état pour ancêtre le
conseil du roi et c'est napoléon
bonaparte en 1799 pendant le concile à
qui la crée aujourd'hui quand un
ministre rédige un projet loi il doit le
soumettre au conseil d'état qui doit
dire si le projet est vraiment utile
s'il est bien écrit s'il est assez clair
s'ils respectent la légalité
le texte ira ensuite devant les
parlementaires pour être discuté puis
voté pour devenir membre du conseil
d'état soit on est nommé par le
gouvernement soit on travaille très bien
à l'école et on y entre grâce à l'ena
l'école nationale d'administration
le président du conseil d'état c'est
officiellement le premier ministre qui
est le chef de l'administration mais
celui qui préside vraiment c'est le
vice-président du conseil d'état c'est à
au fonctionnaire respecter nommé par le
chef
l'état il sera le premier des
fonctionnaires le conseil d'état est
l'institution la plus prestigieuse de
l'appareil d'état par son double rôle de
conseiller et de juge il équilibre
l'action de la puissance publique
enfin ce n'est peut-être pas la vie du
taureau de la sphère tommaso gréco
encore